My name is Allan Quatermain.
It has been about eighteen months since I first met Sir Henry Curtis and Captain John Good.
I was on board the Dunkeld on my way home to Natal after a month of elephant hunting.
At the end of dinner,...
...Sir Henry asked me to go to his cabin and have a whisky with him.
As soon as my glass was full, he said,...
..."Mr. Quatermain, I believe that at about this time last year,...
...you were at a place called Bamangwato."
"That is so," I said.
"Did you meet a man called Neville?" He asked me next.
"George Neville."
"I did," I replied.
Sir Henry drank a little of his whisky,...
...then said, "Mr. George Neville is my brother."
For a few moments, Sir Henry was silent,...
...then he said,...
"Mr. Quatermain, will you please tell me everything you know about my brother, Neville?"
I drank a little of my whisky and then said,...
..."Your brother wanted to find King Solomon's Mines."
"That is why he set out for Inyati."
"I spoke to his servant, a Bechuana we called Jim."
"Where are you and your master going?" I asked him.
"To Suliman country," he replied,...
..."to find the diamonds."
"You'll die," I told him.
"No one has ever come back from there alive."
"I can't stop him from going," Jim said.
Sir Henry said, "Mr. Quatermain, I am going to look for my brother."
"Will you help me?"
"I will pay you whatever you ask if you will come with me," Sir Henry said.
"I am a rich man."
"I can make you one, too."